so back in New York it's been about
three days since I've been back and I
haven't left my sister's house I've been
sleeping over now me why I'm not sure if
you could take me home and I go over to
take an uber we're gonna take Maddy for
a walk
hi then we're going to get brunch and
we're going to ride bikes and do some
fun things since I basically have been
sitting on her couch right there
for almost three days three days Jen
what's wrong with me okay
right now two days wait for a price
under your sundae Oh God hey too close
so times the morning montage to like
montages ha
[Music]
Oh
bringing artists crunch
[Music]
we made it to brunch
Roger never make it real what are we
going to get to brunch Jenna let me get
the scramble clothes 90-foot besides
data well and good you gotta get he's
gonna get rescued a.m. does get some
bacon quite a lot we see him yet here
I'm trying to look at my front-facing
camera now I'm here Hangul over the beat
ten minutes how many minutes he's not
wearing beanies for the past like week
you have a notice actual hat thank you
didn't get all sit next to me you can
open it for me
[Applause]
did you see that Eddie has a hat on
Jenna haven't noticed I did it square
I'm never looking you go you know I'm a
girl weren't crunch I'm vlogging today
guys you excited about it I had never
blog anymore anyway
[Music]
you
all that all that I drink all of it yes
this is comfy God those white the white
looks so fresh I forgot this was in mind
I was like that's not my drink make that
I was kind of fear for them
oh it is very comfy Wow
okay this this actually looks amazing
this whole front is one sheet it is
bigger in size that I thought wait
they're gonna spot my clothes oh I
closed all this is scary
oh my gosh just being take off uncle mom
I suck guys I open those by touching a
button I probably should have got this
instead of my car yeah I mean no I
really really really like my car though
let's call some okay
opening the portal into the office is
cool
we're in people I love it can we read
HDTV one for you this we usually watch
together have you seen this music video
Matt sighs I wasn't even born yet no I
don't think that was warm in the song
[Music]
hey can you take me home na ho I'm being
held hostage at take me home please
we take me home okay I am being held
hostage agenda thousand dollar hostage
taking me to a situation where there's
ice cream and I'm super excited about it
is that rolling on my face yes roll
device join the ice cream without the
ice cream now it's famous on social
media
[Music]
[Applause]
they're making our ice cream right now
and it's really cool they basically code
ice cream on to this really really cold
slab and then it freezes it and then
they roll it up do you think on the old
lab inspiration from your heart or or
what about your sense of humor oh wow
I'll pop out Oh God
the pack not thanks for driving us thank
you appreciate it
David I was getting yelled at well
that's what we do we're women we like to
yell when things who could be said truth
has to happen
[Music]
so that kind of the galaxy yeah this is
the Gaucho
we're going to go for the first taste
test okay I can hear the pop rocks like
hoppin Oh
koalas came by like oh I met Bob Rock so
long yeah no wrong being go oh yeah oh
yeah babe
oh my god is it good Matt you have done
it yes here what's disappointing take
out something like that
Vegas why I said shoot religion go
gallop a fast doesn't mean happening so
that's good that was actually really
like that
the time is there that was so good Jen
yes alright so we're here with a man of
the hour the man of the shop Adam Dahl
owner of Alicia's Creamery in Torrance
we are rolling ice cream here home
making everything what we offer as
anybody come in here and play the little
croissant yet what really okay come on
hold on I got it already I already got
it queued up
I love that they should be rollin rollin
they hatin patrolling
anything else want a baby the Internet I
know I make the best ice cream in the
South Bay oh that's actually true it's
really really good how cool is that a
lab this lab negative 30 degrees well
it's only three than two minutes you
have any ice cream you're just so cool
you guys should come and visit I'll put
a link description we can check it out
and we'll probably be back yeah all that
very good well I can't feel my face when
I'm with you long rocky white coming
guys
[Music]